mr wahlberg
what's up kid
let's go get some treasures you want to
go want some adventures kid we got an
uncharted movie trailer today it's only
got an images so far and supposedly a
leaked 40 seconds or something i was
like i can't watch that because we got
to watch the real trailer that will get
copyright clear yeah
six in the morning i have an open mind
here i played the first two games years
ago and half
of uncharted
they didn't finish it because my disc
crashed i'm sure john's googled some
stuff
i'm proud of everyone here today let's
go
[Music]
there are places out there you can't
find on any map
you're not gone
we're just lost
actual playstation logo at the top yeah
a little young for a bartender aren't
you a little old for farmer
everything in here why the map this path
for magellan to sell around the world
you know your history biggest treasure
that's never been found five billion
easy
okay so changing some stuff here's your
brother well you know my brother said
[Music]
sally doesn't have any friends i should
lie on one of them
so much
i'm blood sure he's just threatening to
kill me don't touch your ear like that
you look like an idiot
i've been dreaming about this stuff
since i was a kid my brother said one
final
[Music]
[Laughter]
whoa
that part is like the
[Music]
what
sound like for that i oh crap he was
specifically that's that's a very
specific nathan drake line all right now
even though i played two and a half
games of uncharted i don't remember
exactly what i played
to the t most of the details i've
completely slipped my memory to me i was
like going into this what i really care
most about
is that
they capture
the tone of it the spirit the
personalities that i really remember
most about nathan drake and sully
and i guess chloe
but mainly nathan drake and salt lake i
think
yeah you know like it's better than i
expected it to be from first hearing
about it i'll say that like when i first
heard about it i went
i don't know about this and then to
actually see the trailer you know i
think it if you've even played some of
uncharted john's played some of the
charts so even he would know like it's
pretty much like indiana jones action
adventure gunsling and archaeologist
kind of character and uh
i'm hopeful
i don't know it's really quite new for
me to be totally honest i think tom
holland is doing the best he can i think
he's a fantastic actor i've seen him in
more than just spider-man he can embody
roles for sure and i think it's easy in
a trailer to go i'm just thinking of tom
holland right here he's been a bit of a
deeper voice this doesn't feel like a
hundred percent peter parker my main
hope is that when i watch the actual
movie i see just the character that he's
going for and i'm not reminded so much
of tom holland mark wahlberg
same thing
might see mark wolberg i don't really
see him embodying sully i imagine he'll
get his famous mustache
closer to uh the end of the movie
because this is a prequel and that's
part of the weird thing to me because
it's a prequel they're changing some of
the origin because i believe it was the
beginning of uncharted three was that
the first one two or three you guys tell
me where you see the or you see you
explore more of the origin with uh
you know his brother sam gr and like
they grew up like uh orphans and such
and how he met sully and they seems like
they really changed that here
and then chloe's from the second game
and the plane scenes from the third game
so it's weird prequel
ideas taking the resident evil movie
approach where we're gonna do a bunch of
our own stuff here's a few things from a
couple of the games to placate everybody
and here we go franchise but it looks
fun it's just weird because uncharted is
probably out of any game i've ever
tampered with it's the most
straightforward you can get with if you
wanted to adapt it i think somehow
this trailer doesn't seem to capture it
might be the music to be honest with you
it doesn't really capture the spirit as
much the swashbuckling spirit i would
say i mean it just looks like a generic
action movie
it does
i mean
yeah when it came to this i was a little
taken aback i suppose because the
uncharted games from all of the glimpses
i've ever had and from everything i
remember seem like they borrow very
heavily from movies which i didn't get
very many hints of those movies from
this this looks more like it wants to be
mission impossible or something like
that and it looks like it all takes
place much more in like a major city
than it does you know in an uncharted
territory where you know ancient
treasures and and traps and things
awaits and with tom holland i mean i
wasn't really that bugged by him in this
trailer not you know like
there are certainly other people who
seem more fitting for nathan drake but
being that they want this to be their
first mission or their first uh you know
adventure together him and sully that
part's fine i just also didn't kind of
get the nathan drake rascalliness from
tom hall and it seemed like they're kind
of molding that character into a you
know a more every man tom holland
protagonist than you know the actual
game character so i don't know i i i
really don't know if i have high hopes
for this based off of this trip like it
looks like a fun and competent fine
action you know adventure doesn't scream
uncharted to me no
not really it does not scream uncharted
no in fact if you didn't put the title
on it i wouldn't know what it's trying
to reference yeah exactly the thing
though is i'm even asking myself let's
say i never had experience with
uncharted what would i think of this tr
i probably admittedly be a tad bit more
optimistic i would still walk away going
it still looks like kind of a generic
action movie yeah yeah i hope has really
great chemistry between its leads
because that looks like the thing
that'll be the star of the movie i mean
that's that's a core that's like such a
core relationship of it like sully is
his like his best friend and
and and like i guess father figure would
be the right term or like you're the
uncle you're close with yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah who will indulge yeah or you
know crazy world trotting predilections
but also keep you a little in line and
give you some sage wisdom and here's
what i'll say too about
ruben fleischer the director of this
movie a lot of the times he has movies
at their trailers for the cinema sorry
his movie trailers
and a lot of the time i walk away going
this looks cheesy and i don't know about
this and then i end up really enjoying
his films he made venom yeah and how
he's directing spider-man
i imagine that i'll still ultimately
have fun when watching this and when it
comes to video game adaptations it's
ultimately all you can really expect now
this weirdly reminds me of is the mummy
tom cruise
i think that's a very accurate call
that's the vibe i got from this trade
in both events tone and general settings
and all that you're not wrong hey guys
are you gonna spend your valentine's
day
four days after to go watch uncharted
what do you think
do you not care are you a tom holland
stan and no matter what he does he he is
god subscribe to tom holland's youtube
channel hit that like button go get some
sleep and hey we'll catch you guys soon